you had a you had a video on instagram
that uh
well you want to get into the the
instagram the vice one
oh yeah so you guys can go check that
out if you were watching
some guy named bill on instagram but um
in the video vice news gives me a call
and they want to do a story on q anon
because i was at a reopened new jersey
a reopened new jersey rally about uh two
or three months ago
i gave a little speech on stage whatever
and i took a picture with some people
who were there they had a they were very
big supporters they had a
cue flag they put up oh yeah q a i pose
in the picture
right i take the pictures i'm like look
we're all on the same page we all
support the president this is all what
it is i didn't think anything of the q
flag when i put it up so
till this day i'm getting emails like
hey you want to tell us a little bit
about your support for q and i we're
doing this story about q and now we want
to write about it
so i'm getting into this thing now
whenever the media contacts me i'm
recording what they're saying just to
kind of make them look stupid because it
doesn't
they don't know what they're talking
about so when you see the video on on
instagram vice calls me they don't know
anything about me they don't know
anything about my
my my campaign and my candidacy other
than the fact that oh we know you won
the republican primary
but we know you also support q and i'm
like well where do you see that i
support q when did i ever say that i
support cure
or anything like that i kind of start
questioning this lady to get to the
bottom of uh
of what she's talking about she couldn't
even answer the question she didn't know
what the hell she was doing
we saw we saw a photo on facebook oh
oh so that's support but what i loved
about this was that you just basically
asked
do you know anything about my campaign
right and the answer was no right
they don't know what your policies are
nope they don't know they probably
i'll tell you this having worked for
many of these companies i'm willing to
bet
that somebody walked up to her and said
here's a list of you know conspiracy
theorists
call them and get a comment yeah and so
there was a point in this video it's
like 10 minutes long where you're
grilling this this reporter from advice
full disclosure i i wish to work for
advice
i actually actually uh was a founding
member of vice news
when it was good and vice news it was
vice news i called you right
it's my spiciness advice is vice versa
they were doing something vice news
tonight on hbo or something like that
yeah
so i i i love this video because you're
like tell me
any one of my policies basically she
can't do it
and that that says so much like you you
pointed out specifically
this is what the news does instead of
trying to figure out
what you're doing to better your
community which includes police reform
which includes you know immigration you
gotta attack uh term limits and all
stuff
they just want the juicy bs that's it
anything to make a sensational headline
you know anything that's gonna get
people to click the article oh look
republican
he's crazy he supports nut job stuff
what's right about it let's click that
you know and and i think that's a shame
because they're overlooking a a lot of
uh
a lot of the things that i actually want
to do in my district a lot of the things
that i want to change in
and not just new jersey as a whole but
across the country i'm pretty sure a lot
of people can benefit from the things
that i want to do
and they don't even want to talk about
that even there's another video i
haven't uploaded it yet and this was
before the vice call this was with uh
washington uh
post uh jeff bezos is a organization
same thing it's not as funny as the vice
one though because the vice one i was
like okay i'm gonna have fun with him
this time because the first time they
called me and i was like the audacity
like you would ask me such a stupid
question like i didn't say that to them
and i'm just like i kind of grilled them
in that in that way
the second time when vice called me okay
let me have fun with them this is going
to be hilarious i want to see if they
even know
i was going to be a little bit more
tactical and um i think i'm going to do
that moving forward every single yeah
call them out you know it reminds me of
uh
jordan peterson yeah he was like he was
at an event and someone pulled out the
cac flag
yeah you know the kick flag yeah yeah
and then all of a sudden he's being told
he has to answer for this flag and he's
like what flag and they're like somebody
held up a flag and took a picture with
you like i take a picture with a ton of
people right
yeah i was i was having a conversation
with somebody because a lot of people uh
it's like
i guess it's become a rumor because i
don't take pictures with people
they were like somebody asked me is it
true that you don't take pictures with
fans
and i was like i don't i for reasons
like this and so i would understand
well it's because people try to set you
up people who are not your fans
do like gotcha moments i was in
washington
and there was a guy sitting down and he
had a little mustache or whatever
and there was a riot going on or
whatever and i was talking to some
leftist guy about something when this
guy walks over and he goes hey you're
tim pool right and i was like yeah he
goes i'm a big fan i was like hey
appreciate shook his hand
and then he says he's a nazi and i'm
sitting there
surrounded by antifa and this guy and
i'm like dude are you kidding me
don't come up to me and bring that stuff
to me i was like i'm not cool with what
that with what you're doing
with what you believe and he was like
that's fine and i was like dude
but so i'm surprised i would have kicked
him in the mouth
that that's that's what i'm a politician
now i can't do that exactly right right
right
so yeah like so when jordan peterson
walks up and someone's like i got a
picture with you and they pull out the
flag
that was innocent right that was someone
like in your instance some guy was like
hey let's get a photo billy and they
pull out a big q flag
now you got all these journalists they
don't know anything about you they see
one photo on facebook and that's
everything that's all they want to know
about
they want to get they want to get clicks
and they want a boogeyman
right and because antifa has been going
nuts for months
q is their boogeyman exactly and it's
it's
and even even when they say that it's
like listen uh
from what i from what i've seen and from
what i've researched there's definitely
something going on there's definitely a
human trafficking pedophilia type
problem going on here
right to the extent of to the extent of
what's going on with the with the whole
cue thing
that i don't know about i can't really i
can't really attest to that but there's
definitely a lot of murky stuff going on
with jeffrey epstein there's definitely
a lot of murky stuff going on
with a lot of these high-profile people
prince andrew and whatnot we've gone to
i mean
and this is the crazy thing because
you've got them trying to conflate
what's going on with epstein which is
like uh don't we literally have this
this lady
in jail right now they're like shuffling
her around word about her and she's
being
charged with like trafficking another
thing like so yeah and and there's a
picture of bill clinton in a blue dress
it's a lock that's what i'm saying i'm
like uh i'll be like listen
regardless of what you believe whether
you whether you support the cute thing
or not
there's definitely something going down
here that just doesn't actually and
and to put it simply they're literally
prosecuting somebody over it
right a guy you know it's it's funny
trump said i wish her well
and then the left goes insane he
supports maxwell they took a picture
back in like
99. but then but then when he gets asked
by that dude from
hbo he's like her boyfriend died
he's in jail and he's dead we don't know
how it happened so yeah
i do wish her well and um that that's
what i thought was gonna happen when he
said it
i thought it was kind of weird when
trump said i wish her well i think he
did it to just like troll man
i think i i think he didn't realize but
i think what he was saying was
i hope she doesn't die i hope because
we're gonna prosecute her we need
we needed to talk right and i think they
tried turning it into he supports her or
whatever
i don't know about it frankly i wish her
well but yeah so anyway
this is what happens with the media and
it's one of the reasons why i've been to
a ton of events
and i'm like i just i don't like doing
events they've threatened to burn down
events i've put on
like i put on an event last year the
ante for threatening to burn it down
we're
just out here just out here we're in uh
south jersey really yup wow
they came from they came from central
jersey down here and then told the press
they wouldn't let
me come to their neighborhood and i'm
like
it's my name i booked it a few miles
from my house right you came down here
from up north
they think they they think they own
anything that you know they can use
violence
you're familiar with daryl davis daryl
davis yeah i have not met there
he's the famous black blues blues
musician who
met a bunch of clansmen and
de-radicalized oh yes yes yes yes yes
yes he was our headline speaker
really they try to shut the event down
why because well because they're just
douchebags
because it's anti-fun man that's what
they do so so daryl davis
tried talking to him because that's his
thing right he like he goes to the plane
he's like hey
you know i'm going to talk to a guy in
the clan and then he ends up
de-radicalizing 200 of these guys
he walked across the street to anti-fun
they called him a white supremacist
madness
yeah dude it's a crazy political world
right now
but i think i think one of the big
things that's that's that's fueling it
absolutely is
it's all fake news they're you know
that's why we watch people like you
well i i mean i guess i'm just a dude
look
i jokingly say i just complain on the
internet like
but the thing is and and one other and
it's the same thing i told you on
twitter it's like one of the main
reasons why i follow and why i really
really really like your show and you're
one of the few people that i actually
watch
on social medias because despite you
having like
you you traditionally have a lot of
liberal views but
you call out the nonsense on that side
too the same way you'll call out the
nonsense on the other side i think well
this is what news is supposed to be a
lot of people give their opinions today
like on cnn it's like don lemon for 40
minutes talking about why
trump is you know satan himself and
you're just calling it the way it is
you know the people on the internet that
are doing the researches and
and looking into information and
actually asking questions getting people
to be
rational and and think for themselves i
think that's the direction that the
media is going to go into and unless the
mainstream media starts to change their
formula
they're going to go away to dodo i kind
of realized something
i think trump is the internet's
politician and biden is the
is the traditional establishment
politician that's actually a good point
because i noticed something trump did
the biggest ad buy
like the biggest ad buy ever on digital
it was like a seven figure one month
you know buy and he bought the most
expensive ad possible the youtube banner
and it was this big news store in the
new york times and and joe biden didn't
buy this
so they're doing the dnc digitally it's
on youtube
and they didn't buy youtube ad space
during their own convention
that doesn't make sense does it like
okay listen if you got a youtube channel
for your digital
convention don't you want people on
youtube to click it to go watch it
right but they didn't buy it so trump
did
however i saw that i started thinking
i'm like
wow so they're not they're not trying to
win they're they're just they're they're
phoning it in they're planning on losing
right
joe biden spent 200 i believe it was 220
million on tv ads
and that's when i realized what it is
nobody's watching tv like that anymore
but but
you look there are a lot of people who
do watch tv
and if you get your news if you're like
one of these regular normie types who
aren't paying attention
you get your news from memes and from
your friends word of mouth right which
trickles down
from cnn msnbc and to an extent fox news
but not so much
if you're watching a show like this
you're going online and seeking out
right but there's an easier way to put
it like if you go to youtube.com
and you and you're searching for like
immigration you're not gonna get only
right wing or only left one you're gonna
it's gonna it could be both right you
know when donald trump says something
like
you know we're gonna build a wall you
search for build a wall you might find
anti-wall and pro wall because the the
algorithm on youtube only knows
wall right unless you say like the wall
is bad then you only get that stuff
but on tv if you're trying to msnbc
you're only getting orange man bad
that's it so these people who are
watching tv
are in that world and it's and i think
what
you know i'm not saying i know this is a
fact or anything it's just an idea i
have
but when i was i was reading this about
the ad buys and then i was reading about
the beltway bubble
in norway bubble yeah so the dc
journalists only follow each other
okay so when one journalist writes you
know donald trump is losing
their buddy season then writes donald
trump is losing and then you get new
york times wall street
you know not wall street journal but
like new york times washington post vox
buzzfeed
trump is losing why because they're all
following each other
they're not hearing what you're saying
not hearing what i'm saying other
political chamber
exactly and that's that's that's that's
probably why
they didn't see trump coming in 2016. so
now you take that
combined with the fact that you know
biden's buying tv and trump's buying
digital and i think trump is the
candidate for the internet age
and it makes sense he trump himself
posted a pepe meme you know he he posts
memes all the time
he gets it man yeah and then you look at
what the democrats are doing and it's
like
phoned in super chat super cringe i
don't know man like did you see the
and i thought this was fake man but did
you see the uh the the performance
i can't remember the guy's name man but
the guy huh what's his name billy porter
the guy with the dress
yep oh my days oh dude i thought that
was a
meme i was like listen man i'm at my
cousin's house and his girlfriend's like
did you see this madness and i'm like
what and i'm like there's no way that's
fruit that looks like
that looks like an adult swim sketch or
something like that yeah and and i'm
like this was
on the d and see if it was like they're
closing major performance it's like
it's like if i'm a democrat and i'm
watching that
i would start questioning like what the
hell am i supporting yeah
did you see that meme which one it's
like it's it's a picture of it
and uh actually let me let me see if i
can pull it up on your instagram
yeah let me uh let me pull up my own
instagram because it's the last thing i
posted and you're gonna you're gonna
love it
so uh it's loading it's loading and
there we go all right check it out oh my
god
read it we're going to lose
all right so for those that are
listening it's that guy billy porter
he's
he's fist pumping and yelling and the
comment on youtube says we're going to
lose aren't we
oh my god it's so perfect i couldn't
believe i was like this
is beyond cringe and the thing that blew
my mind i was like listen you guys got
money dmc
okay this looks like someone made this
in their garage man
i said it was like a freshman high
school talent yeah dude i'm like no
no no no this can't be for real bro this
can't be for so what that's what that
looks like to me
you're talking about all this struggle
and the things the black community and
equality and i'm like
look to me to me it looks like
they're making fun of this like this is
a joke it doesn't look
that's what that's the same thing my
cousin said i was like i was like i was
i'm like is this a joke and they're like
no this is for real and i'm like this
is what they're really putting in front
of people and they're talking about the
struggle of african americans and
they're the champion for black
this is a joke it's not even a virtue
signal they're definitely haha
in our face with this you know man it's
it's it's a recurring theme for me to
talk about but i i do believe
i i know republicans have been saying it
for a long time so it's kind of funny i
i think i've come to this conclusion in
a different path but i think the
democrats are over at racists
oh yeah i think and i wouldn't be
surprised if the whole thing was to just
mock and belittle it and like laugh in
your face you know
it probably was because you know
throughout this entire race
you know with me saying that hey i'm a
republican i'm running as a republican
black people don't give me a hard time
hispanic people don't give me a hard
time the people that give me the hardest
time are the white liberals yeah the
guys the nose piercing and the blue hair
to the side you know
how can you support these people you
don't like black people
you hate your own kind how could you
support the republicans
you know what i mean and it's like these
are the people that are constantly
coming after me it's not the it's it's
not the people in my own community
they're either either faced with one or
two things you know i don't like the
republican party
i don't like what they stand for i like
you and i respect you
or why are you republican in the first
place now i'm curious
yeah one of those two things it's only
these super off-the-wall liberals that
give me a hard time
this this is what i think is really
really fascinating about you know uh
candidates like you candidates like
kimberly klasik and
in in a sense this kind of what i don't
know i guess there's like a new
republican
and it's and it's sort of emerging under
trump you've got people like
like me for instance i've i've been you
know
independent left-leaning i was democrat
i voted for obama the first time
i've always felt like republic like when
i was growing up republicans were bad
you know what i mean
now the republicans are very different
and it's like when i when i see you
i'm like you're i i go to your pl i look
at your platform like
i think i disagree with like one or two
things for the most part but i'm like
you're a cool dude you're from the city
like we get along we
we understand a lot of the same memes
it's like how is it that
you're the new republican you know it's
it's like
i don't know how to describe it it's
like the whole thing is changing
i do think democrats are freaking out
about it yeah because now when you've
got
i don't know if i don't know if it's
true but i'll tell you emerson
rasmussen and i can't remember the other
polls zogby
they show that trump's got 30 percent
approval or at least
they did last uh earlier this year 30
approval among black voters yeah
and i think that freaks them out and i
think realistically it's just from the
people that i've spoken with man
um i think it might be higher than 30
percent i think so like
so you live in a predominantly black
area yeah practically all black and
hispanic you know is it is it
how many people there support trump um
they don't
that's the thing they don't like trump
okay
they like what he's doing they like what
he's doing all right
you know like listen man you'll be
hard-pressed to find somebody and say oh
he didn't help with the job situation
not gonna happen you know i mean
practically everybody that i met is like
yo was it easy to find a job no it was
easier to find a job now than it was
under obama
still f trump i don't like trump you
know you know the covet thing happened
you know trump gave us the check you
know this is cool
you know yeah you know he's funding the
historically black colleges
you know he did the prison reform a lot
of my homies are coming home so
he's still i still don't like him but
they're gonna vote for him
they may they may honestly and if and if
they don't vote for him they're probably
gonna flat out not vote democrat at all
you know because you talk to the average
black person man they know about biden
they know about kamala and they're just
like this is definitely a virtue signal
they're not
this isn't for this isn't for us right
now if trump came out right now
and said i am going to be reviewing
every
non-violent federal drug related defense
it's a landslide three million percent
pardon hundred percent it's gonna be a
landslide bro it's gonna be like what
landslide dude lancers i noticed you
gotta decriminalize marijuana yeah
because i'm like yo bro there's a lot of
people that have their lives my cousins
for example have their lives completely
destroyed for even having
a small bag of weed you know what i mean
i'm like listen i don't care if you
smoke weed or not whether you like weed
or not is besides the point the point
that i'm saying is like i don't know a
single person i haven't seen a single
study of someone who's died from smoking
marijuana
i know people that smoke marijuana for
because they got cataracts they got you
know back problems i have a friend he's
got a fused disc and all kinds of stuff
yeah that's a smoke
friends that have ptsd from the military
that's smoke you know and
it helps them i've seen them all strung
out on percocets and xanax and all kinds
of stuff and
they're fun people to be around when
they smoke weed you know they're not
they're not you know losing their mind
and tweaking out so i'm saying
why should someone have their entire
lives destroyed uh because of that i
don't know if these are your fans
calling but people from all across the
country keep calling my phone
oh you told him your phone number that's
true that's true that's probably it
but um but you know uh i i started
telling a text to you yeah text me if
you guys want to talk i'll respond
i'm a little busy right now yeah i'll
respond to your text messages if that's
the case
but um you know i don't i don't see them
i don't see them
uh saying no to something like that i
was like because for example
governor murphy when he ran one of the
big things he ran on was like oh we're
gonna legalize marijuana
bro i knew so many gangsters bro that
were like that that don't care about
politics at all but they're like yo we
voted for murphy
murphy's about to legalize it you know
and i'm like yo bro but he's not the guy
and i'm like no he's the guy
he wasn't the guy he's definitely not
the guy he's definitely not the guy
murphy's off thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you